foreign
[Music]
for nearly 30 years nvidia's trips have
been coveted by Gamers customers need to
access Nvidia AI easier and faster
Nvidia is going to be the world's
largest company for years haters have
been saying that nvidia's time at the
top is almost over as soon as the custom
PC hype dies down Nvidia will get
crushed as soon as the Bitcoin mining
craze ends Nvidia will get decimated as
soon as the supply chain nightmare ends
Nvidia will be annihilated
but time and time again Nvidia has shown
more resilience than any big Tech stock
on the market for example just last year
nvidia's high 68 sell-off due to the
recession and the general fear is about
tech but unlike in tohu stayed down
Nvidia has already rebounded
158 in fact they're only 20 away from
their all-time highs as we speak this
makes Nvidia the seventh largest company
in the world with a market cap of 650
billion dollars but that's not to say
that the haters don't have some valid
concerns like nvidia's valuation Nvidia
Miss hands down the most richly valued
big tech company even more richly valued
than Tesla take their financials for
example in the past 12 months Nvidia has
only pulled in 4.3 billion dollars in
net income for perspective if Apple was
the same size as Nvidia they would be
pulling in 25 billion dollars or over 5
times more but just because Nvidia has a
rich valuation it doesn't mean that they
won't continue growing in terms of
fundamentals and a market cap in fact
it's highly likely that this is the case
they've got a foot in consumer grade
products a foot in Enterprise grade
products and a ginormous foot in AI but
it wasn't always like this Nvidia has
been around since 1993 and up until 2016
this is how their stock graph looked so
here's how Nvidia went from being a
no-name background company to being the
world's largest semiconductor company
all within a matter of seven years and
why all of this is just the beginning
foreign
taking a look back nvidia's exponential
run can be traced back to early to
mid-2016. at the time Nvidia primarily
served a niche market of Gamers they had
a decent presence in Enterprise their
most notable client was likely a Tesla
if you didn't know it was nvidia's gpus
that were initially powering Tesla's
autonomous Futures but Tesla itself
wasn't exactly a big company in fact
they were simply fighting for their own
Survival and they were actually the most
shorted stock of all time so really
nvidia's main business was selling gpus
to Gamers but all of this would change
with bitcoin's Boron you might be asking
what does Bitcoin have to do with the
gpus well the answer is actually
everything the way that Bitcoins become
available on the market is through a
computationally intense process called
Mining and it turns out that Nvidia gpus
are often the most cost effective way to
mine at various cryptocurrencies since
then many of the top cryptos have
actually become too computationally
intense for NVIDIA gpus to handle or
they've switched to a proof of stake
model which eliminates the need for gpus
but despite this the vast majority of
the most profitable gpus are still from
Nvidia so you can imagine how lucrative
this was back in the day miners would go
out and buy dozens hundreds thousands of
gpus each as you would imagine this led
to an extraordinary amount of demand and
it wasn't long until Nvidia Supply
started running out leading to GPU
prices skyrocketing nvidia's gpus were
regularly selling for 50 to 100 more on
the secondary Market in Nvidia I
actually got a bunch of flag from The
Gaming Community many of them have felt
that Nvidia was selling into this faded
instead of supporting their main
demographic they felt that Nvidia should
be implementing quantity limits and the
nerfing the mining power of their cards
to ensure that Gamers could still get
gpus for MSRP but this didn't exactly
happen Nvidia very much played into the
mining craze and let the minor establish
a new normal price for gpus this did
lead to a mini movement against Nvidia
where a bunch of Gamers switched to AMD
AMD was crushing it against Intel with
the Horizon Series so many gamers were
hopeful that they would also be able to
take on Nvidia but this never really
materialized while AMD has been able to
hold their own against Nvidia Nvidia is
still very much the GPU King but it
wasn't all good news for NVIDIA back in
2018 bitcoin's price would peek out at
the end of 2017 and it would
dramatically Crush 83 right after this
took out much of the appeal of crypto
Mining and it didn't take long for
miners to leave the scene for gamers
this was nvidia's Judgment day they had
to pay the price for siding with miners
instead of Gamers and I guess they did
pay some price once the mining craze
died down Nvidia stock would have
dropped 57 but with that being said the
mining boom allowed Nvidia to grow 11x
in the prior 18 months so I don't think
they were exactly sad if anything if
they were optimistic as they were
determined to make the price increases
due to mining permanent
foreign
was expecting for GPU prices to plummet
as soon as the miners left but Nvidia
had a different idea you see it just as
the mining craze was dying down Nvidia
would come out with the 2000 series of
gpus let's just say it was substantially
more expensive especially when it came
to high-end cards the GTX 1080 for
example launched for 600 the RTX 2080
though came in at 700 to 800 the real
difference was in the ti series though
the GTX 1080 TI launched for 700 the RTX
2080 TI however came in at one thousand
to eleven hundred dollars or 50 percent
more nvidia's justification for these
price increases were that they added Ray
tracing technology which is a notable
upgrade but it didn't exactly warrant a
price hike and the proof can be seen in
nvidia's financials between 2016 and
2018 nvidia's net margin would it nearly
triple from 13 to 37
clearly the cost difference that at RTX
was going straight to nvidia's bottom
line but but Gamers were still hopeful
they were optimistic that Nvidia would
realize that these prices were
unaffordable for most Gamers and that
they would eventually decrease prices
but Nvidia would stubbornly hold on and
Gamers would eventually compromise the
ones that didn't would end up having to
pay even more as Nvidia would experience
yet another boom in 2020 as everyone now
knows 2020 would bring with it the
pandemic which caused everyone to stay
at home this led to an unprecedented
number of people buying gaming PCs and
getting into gaming but the penamagot
didn't just bring more demand it also
brought less Supply when China is shut
down at every other week and there are
new obstacles in every step of the
production process from factories to
Logistics it's no wonder why companies
entered a supply chain crisis for
companies that relied on volume of goods
sold it this was devastating but for a
company like Nvidia who could just jack
up the prices this was a quadrash and it
don't even get me started on the
secondary markets remember how prices
were hiked 50 to 100 during the mining
boom well this time prices would be
hiked 3 5 10 x people were literally
auctioning off gpus as if it was some
sort of antique product and Nvidia would
of course just feel the fire with yet
another series of cards the 3000 Series
this time Nvidia took the Apple approach
they realized that they get a bunch of
backlash when they increase the price of
a given Series so they decided why not
just add another tier of gpus like the
iPhone Pro Series and with that we saw
the launch of the RTX 3090 for 1500 and
the RTX 3090 TI for two thousand dollars
but it didn't stop right there either if
you're familiar with Bitcoin you know
that it usually follows a four year
cycle and it had already been four years
since 2016. so yes the miners were back
and at this time Nvidia was ready for
them in early 2021 Nvidia would go ahead
and end a Nerf gaming gpus with software
so that they couldn't be used for mining
instead they would go ahead and launch
mining specific gpus that cost forty
seven hundred dollars originally Gamers
were hoping that such a move would be
beneficial for them but now they were
paying a ludicrous amount and the miners
were paying an even more ludicrous
amount if you thought the gamers and the
miners were lucrative though just to
wait till you hear what gold mine they
tripped on next
it turns out that gpus aren't just
capable of making your games look better
they're also a requirement for machine
learning and AI training I'm sure you
know about chat GPT by now chat GPT was
trained using a bunch of Nvidia gpus
called the h100 the h100 runs between 10
and 20 000 depending on what specs you
get we can call it 15 000 on average
this is obviously an unreasonable amount
for you and me but surely that's nothing
for a company right well that would be
the case Until you realize that Chachi
PT needed 10 000 of these suckers just
for the initial training if you haven't
done the math yet that's 150 million
even accounting for a discount to the
skill we're talking about a hundred
million and that that was just for phase
one of development for one project given
the success of chat GPT you can bet that
every tech company and their mothers
want a piece of the pie the most notable
example is probably Google bard over the
past couple of years Google has tried to
develop their own computational devices
called tpus but Google has by no means
been able to replace Nvidia in fact I
don't even think they're trying to
replace Nvidia as they're actually
promoting Nvidia products they're
literally cloudifying in media gpus and
making that into its own business if
buying this much computation power for
your AI business is a bit too much don't
worry you can just rent it from Google
instead most tech Giants however are of
course opting to just work with Nvidia
directly Tesla for example is using 5716
Nvidia a100 gpus to train their
self-driving each of these gpus costs
are called 10gs so Tesla setup costs 57
million dollars not including the setup
maintenance and the lease a similar
story can be seen with meta as well
they've actually been using Nvidia GPU
since 2017 when they got access to 22
000 of their V100 gpus as you can see
Nvidia is not just a monopoly in this
sector there are literally the only
viable solution and that's not because
of a lack of competition companies like
AMD Intel Qualcomm tsmc and the AWS all
see this opportunity it's just
extraordinarily difficult to catch up to
Nvidia when they have a lead of 20 to 30
years in the GPU scene so let's just say
Nvidia isn't going anywhere anytime soon
foreign
all this you might be saying that Nvidia
just got lucky with all these booms they
just got lucky that there was a gaming
boom and then a mining boom and then a
machine learning boom and then an AI
boom but that's completely untrue luck
is what happens when preparation meets
opportunity the reality is that Nvidia
saw this Vision 30 years ago in 1993 and
simply wasn't until 23 years later that
the rest of the world realized how vital
this technology really is first it was
The Gaming Community then it was the
mining Community then it was the
Enterprise community and now it's the AI
Community but these are by no means the
last to realize the potential of gpus
while it's unfortunate that it took so
long for everyone else to get on the
same page this gave Nvidia an
extraordinary amount of time to cement
themselves as the Undisputed King and
unlike Intel who blundered their lead by
stagnating Nvidia is still innovating as
fast as ever which has made it
impossible for anyone asked to outdo
them now of course all companies will
eventually become like Intel but that's
not happening to Nvidia in the imminent
future here's what's happening instead
Tech itself is a gold mine and you have
all these companies Google Microsoft
Tesla Apple Facebook all digging for
gold so far they've been pretty
successful at finding gold but whether
they hit gold or not doesn't matter fan
video because they're the ones selling
the shovels and that's why Nvidia will
become the world's largest company the
only company that can steal this title
from Nvidia in my opinion is Tesla do
you agree comment that down below also
drop a like if you would like to see
more Tech case studies and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community suggestions for video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions that logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]
foreign